Surprise!
Bonus Thursday video on my channel.
Feel both offended
and excited.
This is a bonus video this week.
For two reasons..
One..
I have purchased this
family fun make-up kit..
Thinking I was gonna do
some sort of..
funny, hilarious uh
Halloween
make-up tutorial type of thing.
And instead I made a video about
how to be a Disney princess daughter.
But right after I shot that video,
I was seeing all these make-up tutorials..
about how to make yourself into
uh, an emoji.
And I realized no one was making themselves
into my favorite emoji.
Which..
is this.
*mumbling*
I wanna give him space.
It's the old man emoji.
And so I thought today
I would try to make myself into the old man emoji.
Some of you will probably
wanna be this for Halloween
because it's gonna be great.
No, how can you live up to--
How can you live up to that?
Why am I even trying this?
And the second reason that
I'm doing this video
is because I am part of the Ad Council's new campaign
I Am a Witness.
An anti-bullying campaign,
which I am really excited that they even asked me to be a part of.
The I Am a Witness campaign
is launching today!
October 22nd.
Talking about bullying
sucks.
Because I think we've all been bullied.
I think talking about bullying is a great way
to kinda take the power out of bullying.
You know, the more you say
one word over and over again
the less meaning it has in your brain.
And with that, the Ad Council has
created an Anti-Bullying campaign
centered around an emoji
not the old man emoji.
I know. I know, but that would be a weird message
and wouldn't be direct and would take a lot of explanation
Instead they chose this.
The purpose of the eye emoji
is to use it when you are a witness to something.
"Eye" Am a Witness
Send it to the bully or the bullied..
through a text message or through social media
however it makes sense to you..
to just let them know you see what's happening.
I will put all the links
in the description box below
that you would need if you are interested
in this campaign.
And I hope you are because
I am.
And use the eye to let people know you are
a witness.
Or recreate this old man emoji face..
Halloween tutorial.
And then just saddle up to the bullies
when they least expect it.
Maybe in a dark alley when they're all alone..
maybe in their rooms when they're sleeping..
and just wake 'em up
a little bit and
then say,
"No one will believe you this is happening."
"Stop being awful..."
"to everyone else and this will stop."
If that seems like a lot
to do maybe just download the keyboard.
Grace VO: So before we officially begin..
we're gonna brush out our dirty, gross hair
into a ponytail.
So that we can foreseeably put it under a bald cap.
But we don't have a bald cap
so we can just put it in a ponytail
and pretend.
If you can get your hands on a bald cap,
congrats!
Stop bragging.
But we couldn't, so I'm gonna use a nude tanktop instead
I'm gonna replace it over my hairline
like a bald cap
Be impressed by how great it looks for a second
then go back to being terrified that I'm actually
putting a tutorial on my channel.
I'm gonna tie it in the back
and we find that it looks terrible in the back
because you only see me from the front
You go out in the real world
you  might want to fix the back.
Then I'm going to poorly handle
some foundation.
And then try to blend it into my face
to blend my fake bald cap
into my fake facial coloring.
Which I don't know that any of this is actually helping.
I think I just wanted to pretend I was a beauty guru for like a second..
doing something with coloring.
I think I might be color blind.
I then tried to use concealer
to blend in my eyebrows
and quickly realized that concealer
does not blend in your eyebrows.
So watch other beauty gurus to figure out how
to blend in your eyebrows.
Then I got to use my make-up kit
that I bought after
I turned it right side up.
And I tried to use some of the colors in there
to blend in eyebrows
and quickly learned
I just don't know how to do it.
Maybe watch someone like Kandee Johnson..
So then I moved onto pouring old
timey dust all over my face.
AKA setting my foundation with
translucent powder.
From there, I moved onto bronzing
my face because when you look at this emoji
the entire outline of his face is very tan.
And contoured.
This man is retired.
And living in--
he is not alive.
Which is important to recognize.
After this, I messed around with my lighting set up a bunch.
Like I knew what I was doing.
I continued to contour my face.
Like I was a beauty guru on an actual mission.
Rather than a solo Lewis and Clark
just trying to get by.
Then I took an eyebrow pencil
and decided to draw the three prominent
wrinkles on the old man emoji
forehead.
And took a look at myself and realized
this is actually working out.
Absolutely nothing can go wrong from here.
And then grab the black pencil from the Halloween
makeup kit.
Draw the oversized smiley mouth and realize
I hated it.
So I used instead the black face paint
from the Halloween make up kit.
And realized oh my gosh!
So I just submitted to my own terribleness
and drew the two shaded lines that
come down from the old man emoji's mouth.
Then I went through a very long series
of trials and tribulations.
I--well, tribulations on tribulations..
of trying to make larger cartoonish emoji eyes..
using white face make up
and black eye shadow
black eyeliner before ultimately realizing
I'm not capable of this!
So again, watch Kandee Johnson.
I took off all the terrible tries off my eyes
and just went with some plain foundation
covered eyes with some black eyeliner
in the corner trying to make the eyes pop.
Then I moved onto making the grey tufts
of hair that the emoji has.
I took some cardboard
and cut it into two half circles.
and covered it in duct tape
to get the grey color and
duct taped it to the side of my head
in a very crude alien, elderly Minnie Mouse like fashion..?
I went back through and tried to fix
the mouth with some liquid eyeliner
and there you go.
The creepy..
It wasn't supposed to be creepy!
But it is definitely creepy!
Old man emoji..
Halloween costume.
I hope on some level this made you want
to download the "I'm a Witness" keyboard
for Ad Council's
"I'm a Witness" anti-bullying campaign.
I don't know.
*music*